hi everyone so I'm not and I'm here to
present you a project that I did after
completing a deep learning course given
by the Machine and deep learning Israel
community this project was together with
the next cell and it dealt with
detecting obstacles on the road so
before I start I wanna say that I did
this entire project together with Chaco
if you have any question she's back
there sitting so what was our project
about advanced driver assistance systems
one of their main functions is to allow
you to try the drivers when there are
some obstacles that the car might a run
into so basically we need to know where
they are in a large driver and if you
look at the common ways to do this for
example if we have semantic segmentation
on the Left where every pixel in the
image needs to be classified whether
it's a car a pedestrian the road etc or
the object detection when we need to
actually detect the all the objects in
the image for example you could look at
the car over here that's very far away
and it's not actually posing any danger
because we have a car that's closer to
us and both of those met a common
practices are very heavy computationally
and requires a lot of time and while
driving we needed to perform in real
time so in 2015 a word called stick so
net was published the innovation in this
work is that instead of looking at the
entire picture now we're looking at the
stick so basically this narrow column of
a part of the image and in this stick so
what the network needs to provide us is
the location where the first obstacle
begins mainly we're just dividing the
stick cell into a bins and the network
outputs the bin word a obstacle begin
you can see here mark in red so the golf
our project was a to implement a faster
version of stick select and why is that
because the original architect
sure had to convolution layers and then
three fully connected layers and the
fully connected layers requires a lot of
parameters and they take a lot of
computational time so what we did was
implement two architectures the mobile
81 and the mobile net fit to both of
those a architectures are very fast
they're fully convolutional there are no
to be lite version and still get good
results in this project we use the Qt
database it's a publicly available
database basically it's a database of
car driving around and there is images
from the driving there is a depth
information and it's all available so
for the depth information Dunlevy the
author of the Stix Lynette paper he
published and the ground truth results
that were extracted automatically and
after finishing the pre-processing we
had about 1 million stick CIL's and
about the third of them had the ground
truth data so now let's talk a little
bit about the metrics to see how we can
evaluate the performances of the
networks so as you recall I said that
we're dividing each stick cell into bins
and then we want to know if the if the
network a a classify the same the stick
cells where that actually the obstacles
starts if it does fall on the same bin
then we say it's correct and if it
misses so it doesn't care we don't count
it if then we want to know the
percentage of stick souls that were
accurately classified and we call it the
top one accuracy we have a another
metric and this magic here is the graph
I'll start so in the bottom we have the
number of pixels that we allow the
obstacle to begin in and then on the
y-axis we have the percentage or the
fraction of the results that were
classified correctly within this range
of error so if we look at an error of 10
pixels in this example we have about 85%
of the stick cells that were classified
correctly and we're interesting in
in the area under curve of this graph so
let's look at a little bit of the
results on the first line we have the
stick zonal which is the architecture
that I told you before was published in
the paper and here we have two and a
half architectures that we implemented
the mobile net be one the mobile node v2
and the mobile node V 2 with a geometric
kernels basically it was in a
rectangular shape because the stick
CIL's are very elongated and in the
original paper they also used a
symmetric kernels so we wanted to see if
it will improve our results we found out
that it didn't but we tried it anyway so
if we look to compare between those
networks in the stick solid we had more
than 20 millions parameters which is
quite a lot and in the mobile net we got
it about an order of magnitude less we
had less than 5 million parameters for
the would be 1 and less than 2 million
for the V 2 if we look at the top one
accuracy the stick so net does perform
better mmm but by about 10 percent even
9 percent actually and when we're
looking at a and you see we consider
that the results are very very similar
we basically got to the same performance
if you look at it as a graph so on the
right you see the a graph from the paper
we're comparing to the softmax loss
because it's a classification problem
and on the left you can see our results
in all of them the area under curve is
about 0.8 four or eight five eight six
in the 611 but a paper we were very
satisfied with those results and also
it's interesting to look at the images
to see how actually the network
performed so on the bottom you see the
ground truth and on the top you see our
prediction and so first of all we can
say that the results are satisfying and
also I think it's a very interesting to
look where the network actually missed
and misclassified some things so if we
look at the fence we see that there is a
lot of noise there in where the obstacle
begins
it can be due to several reasons for
example if there are not a lot of
offenses in the data set the data set is
not that big and also there is a rapid
change of the colors and many edges
which also is hard for our network and
if we're talking about edges you
considered in the shadow of the car
it also means classified the shadow as a
beginning of an obstacle which is again
talking about a sharp edge of the colors
but also something that I found really
interesting is if we look at the red
sign on the left of the right image we
can see in the bottom that it actually
the automatic rancher didn't classify it
didn't classify it completely correctly
we can see that the legs are classified
correctly on the top image what but our
algorithm has output well actually it
counted as a miss in our metrics but
it's the better result so I just want to
share a few things that we learned along
the way and it was our first product
project and we did some rookie mistakes
we can call it that people should avoid
or at least learn from other people's
experience so first of all real life
data is dirty it's unbalanced you need
to work really hard to clean it and you
shouldn't forget that and also it's
really good to achieve convergence on a
small data set and make sure it is
balanced because otherwise you didn't
get actually anything what else we did
is was building a pipeline with the data
set API or in the estimator API those
days ap highs didn't have a lot of
documentation while we were working on
them so um we had to be creative when
we're searching for solutions and one of
the stories I really like is the chalk
I'll actually found the solution to one
problem in a comment of the YouTube
tutorial yeah true story so also we
signed the results that the mobile
architectures showed the similar results
and we had about 10% of the parameters
and also check the predicted values and
the network certains a certainty along
the way it's
important to see that your network
actually you learn something and true
you're not just looking at noise the
performing for some reason a little bit
better than random and also I wanted to
share it to really good resources
containing many advice on how to train
your neural networks and avoid common
mistakes and that's it thank you very
much questions the mistakes was far away
and like quite close to the real
obstacle right you can think about all
kinds of life pieces metals we drive out
there is something about um so it was in
our future plans to work on other
metrics data I'll go to the metrics
slide let's talk about the distance but
also the oops the area under curve does
get you some information about how far
away we are from the correct
classification and also in the paper
itself we didn't do it because they got
really similar results but they also
looked at it as a regression problem
they tried a lot of things and we
started with classification because we
thought it would be faster and will
still give us interesting results so the
question was how long did it take us and
I think we worked about it for about two
months about a two or three days a week
I think and yeah Shaco seems to agree
with me yeah so it was a lot of we were
both working like part-time jobs and we
invested a few days and many evenings I
think thank you very much
you
hi everyone I'm in a turned-out formula
world and I'm going to talk about one of
the scariest thing in data science data
leakage so what is data leakage
according to Google data leakage is the
creation of unexpected additional
information in the training data
allowing the model to make
unrealistically good predictions or in a
simpler version just anything that will
make your research performance be better
than your production performance so in
this talk I'm going to demonstrate some
best practices to how to avoid how to
discover and how to investigate that the
leakage we've two examples our first
example is about loan default prediction
model so I had data about loans to small
businesses and we're trying to predict
if the loan is a good loan like this one
where all of the payments as returned on
time or a bad loan like this one with
one of the payment it was late default
loan
so I ran my first chin learning model
and got this Aussie at first I said wow
this is an amazing result and after a
second of pure happiness I said yeah I
have a data leakage again so okay this
is way to discover that a leakage is
just to save it the model performance is
too good to be true here it was
definitely the case so what what can you
do the first thing I did was looking for
bugs like entering the labels the
feature to the model this wasn't the
case here so I started digging into the
model future importance is a very good
way to discover leakage here we can see
that the number of payments is very
strong feature in the model this man is
suspicious due to two reasons first of
all according to my domain knowledge
this shouldn't be such a strong feature
and second feature potus distribution is
usually more logarithmic shape but not
one very strong feature like here so now
we have another indication for a leakage
and we know what feature to focus and
our good practice is looking
interpretable models like decision tree
is olena
here we can save it at the root of the
tree we had about 60% bad loans and
after the first plate in the red we have
almost 85% this is a very good split
that doesn't really make sense so this
is probably a leakage so what was the
leakage we had data from only 18 months
so had a problem with the long term
loans well it don't like this one the
tendency started as a set so obviously
we could use them who had loans like
this one but so far good loans but we
don't know what will happen next so we
can't use them a new hand loans like
this one but didn't ended yet but I
already did know that one payment was
late so this is the default loan and we
used it for the model this created the
bias within the long loans group who
have almost only a default label which
is not the how did reality works so we
fix this bias by including only loans
which were planned end date has already
passed my second example is from the
medical field we had data about patients
with had wearable devices on them and
we're trying to predict if patient would
have an abnormal event or an attack of
his disease using the variable data here
in the plot we can see the activity of a
patient at night and in red you can see
is the activity during an attack so i
ran my mother and got this OC this is
not such a good hour see like the first
one but it has a perfect pallet in its
beginning straight or almost straight
lines in the RCL user indication for a
leakage with the mothers but that is
exploiting so I started investigating
the model this time I did it with lime
lime is a very cool Python package that
like to explain specific prediction of
liquids models I took the examples with
the highest probability from the model
and
static okay starting looking at them
with lime I saw that the explanation of
sleep time between 7:00 half and nine
and a half hours has returned in most of
them this man is suspicious
because this is this didn't really
connected to my domain knowledge so
after investigating this explanation I
did a bit more I found with it almost I
saw it's completely only one patient so
in that asset we had groups in them like
this one we can't use a normal condo
cross-validation and we do use group
cross-validation where we train on
several patients and test another this
way we can make sure that our model will
generalize to new patients when it will
go to production here we can see every
eye will see is the LLC of one fold in a
four fold Gold Coast validation
containing different patients every time
we can see that three out of the four
folds are almost completely random and
only one fold performs well so ever here
we have here a good leakage so what was
the leakage we had the few patients with
a very large attack percent and this
made the model learn how to predict if a
patient is a good patient or a bad
patient and not the actual patterns of
an attack we fix it by making it harder
for the model to distinguish between
patients by normalizing the features per
patient and evaluating with Gulf Coast
validation the way they too good to be
true method the perfect party that will
see the problematic feature importance
the high variance in cross-validation
and inspecting interpret role models so
here is some tips to avoid data leakage
in the first place first of all be
suspicious data leakage can happen to
everyone in a million different ways my
best advice is to always think about it
and suspect every result you get domain
knowledge is critical here you need to
have a full understanding on your
problem domain in order to say that
something doesn't make sense they need
further investigation like I did a few
times in the examples learn your
evaluation you need to start your
project by thinking about how will you
evaluate to the new model how can the
production data be different from my
research data
do I have groups like in the second
example do I have time series like the
first example maybe I will have new
categories and many more
these questions other views so I really
like code reviews maybe the only one in
the world like a co-worker data
scientist and just explaining your
methods what features you extract how to
evaluate what pre-processing do you do
and hopefully we'll find some problems
or at least at least point you to some
potential pitfalls
well Katella tively I know what y'all
want to try the new deep CN n alanine
residual transform the attention of guns
with some cyber block to layers of
buzzwords but it's not a good way to
start a project starting with a simple
model with a small number of features
and making more and more complex
iteratively gives you full power on your
research and if you see something that
doesn't make sense
you can easily come back to the version
that it was added and find your problem
and finally in the words of Joseph
fellow from catch-22 just because you're
paranoid doesn't mean we're aren't after
you open I do a little paranoid thank
you very much
[Applause]
hi guys I'm Alex I'm here
to talk about the multi-level
multi-label classification sorry Oh a
few words about me I'm a developer and
and/or data scientist at two ago and
these are my contact and what I'm want
to do today is to explain a bit about a
multi variable classification what it is
and then show some techniques and
methods how to access and solve these
problems using some code but not a lot
of code so don't be afraid and okay
so before talking about the multi-label
classification let's talk about regular
classification I'm sure most of you are
familiar with it but but the other I
want to make clear so regular
classification we want to understand an
object and tag it to a binary answer so
for example hot dog or not hot dog of
the art regular binary classification
and the multi-label classification is
not much bigger problem of that but it's
like a bit difficult so in here we don't
want to label it into a binary yes-or-no
answer but into binary vector for
example in his in this picture we can
see there is a house and a grass and a
flag in the sky so instead of asking is
there a house in this picture is years
there is the regress we want to ask one
question and label all this answers so
basically the input is some data and the
output is a binary vector of yes or no
and so who needs it
so actually anyone who does regular
binary binary classification will
probably need need multi-label
classification sometime as in image
categorization as I showed earlier in
text categorization if you want to
classify text into a subset of of
categories and medicine environment for
ethics and
so before I show some techniques I want
to get something straight and multi
level versus multi class which sometimes
it confused if when we're talking about
multi class it's a regular
classification but it's not binary
meaning the rating system are rated so
it can get there several different
values and the gender is a subset of all
the gender it could be so clear okay now
to the code so there's a bunch of stuff
here how to generate the date and the
sources and some explanation I will not
go for this you can check it after your
afterthought
so how do you approach approach by a
multi-label classification problem the
first technique is the transformation
methods with which is actually to take
the multi label and turn it into single
label binary problem which we know
pretty well how to solve so the the
binary relevance does exactly this so
suppose we have a problem we have a data
which is X and we want to label it into
several labels Y one till yy4 and take
our favorite a single label
classification classification algorithm
and run it four times on the on the data
and get four answer and then merge them
all together so this will work but it
takes some time and if there are any
connection between the labels it will
not get it so in order to get the
connections we can use something called
classifier chains
which is work it's also iterative and
works basically no but it works pretty
much the same we have the same data we
run it on the first classifier we get
the answer for y1 and then we get the
output for y1 add it to our data and run
it on y2 and so on so this is a this is
sounds pretty weird if you see it on
first time but actually it does it does
make sense I can show you using example
I hope everyone can see it
so basically here we want to label some
a movie into a subset of of categories
so we first who asked if the movies
Romans or no Roman on non Romans and we
get an answer that's not yes then we had
the Romans into the movie data and asked
if it's horror or not horror yeah and we
get it's not so what why does it make
sense because if you if we look at the
movie genres in a graph the Romans and
the horror are pretty far away pretty
really far apart from each other so when
when we get an answer for something that
it is Romans it it takes the answer more
to the Romans part and not to the horror
so basically this is kind of the
intuition behind the behind the stuff em
but it also takes a number of iteration
as the number of dead of our labels the
first the third and the last technique
of turning this data into a single label
question is not to and not to look at
the labels as columns but rather as a
rolls so we can name the first row as
one and the second one is two and the
third one is three
and then we can see at 1 again and 4 & 3
so we took our multi-label
classification problem and we turn it
into a single label but with multiple
various multiple values which is much
easier to solve and we have a number of
non algorithms for that
so it works fine on some set of problems
but if you have a very large subset of
labels and they are different from one
another you can have a lot of different
values which might be difficult to solve
and so the next technique is adapted
algorithm and so as you know we have
multiple algorithms for multi-label
classification for a single label
classification okay a K nearest
neighbors decision tree some boosting
neural networks and all kind of stuff
and some very smart people at
universities thought of it and adapted
it into the multi-label problems so for
here for example I have an I have as an
example multi-label a KN I'm sure you're
familiar with you can an algorithm I'm
not going to explain it about the
multi-level KNN because I don't fully
understand and it's pretty hard but here
I have a link for the original article
and you can yeah
you can check it for yourself and the
problem with that with this algorithm is
is that we don't have too much adaptive
algorithms I mean not not every single
label algorithm was adapted into
multi-label so but if you have an
algorithm that you want to use and it
has a multi-level version so and the
last technique is unsampled learning
well I think in machine learning
in the quad in clustering and in every
machine learning problem more the more
our classifiers here on the more
algorithms Iran is better so basically
what and sample learning means is that
you take your data then you have some
random subset of your data run it
multiple times on various algorithms and
then get multiple results merge them and
you get your answer so here in cyber
learning works the same but instead it's
not only a subset the input data but
also the output the de labels so you
have a for each run you have a subset of
the input data you have a subset of the
of the labels and then you run some of
the previous techniques that I showed
you run it multiple times until you are
satisfied you merge the results and of
some answer this answer is not so good
this was all run on rain on the random
data so just to show how to run this
algorithm is not real data and that's it
thank you
[Applause]
hi I'm Lee R I'm an independent
researcher and today i'll speak about
hyper networks which is a new idea in
deep learning basically a hyper network
is just a neural network whose task is
to generate waits for another given
neural network so I call this given your
network I call it the target network and
our hyper network will generate waits
for the target network and some of the
applications of this idea are first of
all one hyper network could be used to
generate a lot of different weight
vectors or the same target target
network and combining all these
different weight vectors you could get
an in Samba and improve your prediction
accuracy another application of hyper
networks is in the context of
reinforcement learning so if for example
you have an agent which you want to
Train by competing against itself then a
hyper network can be used to generate
instead of this one agent competing
against itself you can generate a lot of
different agents and then your agents
will be able to generalize better so
I'll just say a few words about about
generative methods in general so I'm
talking about methods a Gans or
variational auto-encoders and for our
purposes I don't really care how you
train again for example I just care how
you operate a trained again so if you
have a trained gun generator for example
all it is is this it's just a real
network and to operate it you need to
sample a random vector Z feed the vector
into your neural network and then you
get at the output for example an image
and the idea here is that if you take
different vectors in the input you get
different images at the output so your
your generator has the capacity to
generate different images of diversity
of images and
I was curious about the question which
other things we can generate with a
generator
besides images and text and this is
familiar familiar examples and I asked
myself whether we could actually
generate weights for a neural network
using a generator and okay I'm sorry the
slides are corrupted for some reason but
so so so a hyper network is exactly what
I described it's just a generator that
whose task is to generate weights for a
given neural network and you operate a
trained hybrid Network just like you
operated what this like I destroyed
before you feed a random vector said in
the input and you get at the output
vector of weights for your neural net
important thing here is that the weight
vector that you get at the output if you
use it in your target Network then it
gives you good results so for example if
our target Network is a classifier and
you use the weights that you generated
with your hyper network then your
classifier will classify correctly at
least most of the time questions at the
end I think yeah I know I'm talking I
want my generator to be able to generate
weights final weights so that if I use
them in my target network I don't need
to train anymore
I have weights which work well okay okay
so so using the procedure of gans
for example to train a hyper network
won't work here because again requires a
data set and in our case we don't
usually have a data set of weight
vectors so so we need something else
here actually training this is
relatively simple the concept is simple
all you need to do is just combine your
hyper network with
target Network into one big combined
Network treated treated is the one
network and just use standard back
propagation so so our target our target
network which has some it needs to solve
some tasks for example classification
and it comes with a given loss function
and whereas in standard training of a
network which is back propagate using
this last function and update the
weights of our network in our case we
continue the back propagation and update
the weights of the hyper network instead
of the target network and that's how we
get a trained hyper network now if I if
I train they could just explain I run
into a problem which is that the hyper
network learns to ignore the input and
always generate the same output and I'm
not interested in that because I lose
the ability to generate a lot of
different wave weight vectors using my
hyper network so to solve this problem
what I need to do is what we need to do
is is add another term to our last
function so it won't won't be only the
classification loss that we have we also
add a diversity term that adversity will
encourage diversity and the the one
example for a diversity term that we can
use is entropy so the larger the entropy
of the generated weights then the more
diverse the more different they are from
each other and I have this parameter
lambda which can balance between these
two terms because there's a trade-off
between them so a few words about the
architecture of hyper network so the
output of the hyper network is a weight
vector and a weight vector could be very
large it could be tens of thousands or
millions of dimensions because that
that's the
of our target networks typically and we
won't we don't want our hyper network
size to explode so we somehow need to
restrict its size and one way of doing
this is by weight sharing so the idea is
you take your RAM new vector is Zed you
try you use this block to transform it
into a lot of small vectors and each one
of these small vectors is just one
compressed representation I have a
filter in the target Network and so you
have a lot of weight vectors and that's
sorry you have a lot of little vectors
now you want to convert each one of
these little vectors into the actual
weights of the filter and to do this you
use this you use a block which is this
the little neural net neural net and the
idea here is to reuse the same block for
Trent transforming each one of these
little vectors into the weights of a
filter and by using the same block with
the actual same weights you get weight
sharing and and you can keep your hyper
network small enough and more more
scalable so I tried these ideas on an
example of amnesty amnesty is the data
set of images of handwritten digits and
for the target Network
I took us convolutional network with
four layers and I wanted I trained a
hyper network and I wanted to see two
things I wanted to see if my accuracy
and I wanted to see the diversity so for
the accuracy it's it's a simple thing to
measure because it could just generate a
lot of different weights using my hyper
Network and measure the act the
prediction accuracy of each one of these
weight vectors and plot a histogram for
example and my results were satisfying
because they got that all the weight
vectors that I generated obtained high
accuracy but now I need to make sure
that but I also have a diversity in
other words I need to make sure that
these weight vectors are are different
from each other and they're not actually
all the same weight vector so it's not
as straightforward to measure diversity
there are a few ways and the first thing
we could do is is Foreman in Samba if
you Foreman sambal using all your weight
vectors you could see whether your
prediction accuracy improves with then
sambal compared to single weight vectors
and if it improve improves it means that
the weight vectors are sufficiently
different from each other
so that the variance of their prediction
decreases and indeed that's why I saw so
that that was a good indication that I
have a diversity
another thing is using the in sambal I
got a better immunity to adversarial
examples which also indicates that
there's diversity here the one last
thing to probe this space of weights
which I can generate I could use PCA
principle component analysis I can
generate a lot of weight vectors and
each weight vector is a very high
dimensional vector but I can plot this
high dimensional point these high
dimensional points in the first
principal components so this is what you
see here
so you see here scatter plots of
principal component one versus PC two
and PC one versus PC three and so on you
see a few combination of [ __ ] here and
the interesting thing I think here is
that we don't get like a simple Gaussian
blob which is what you would expect if
you didn't have a diversity because in
that case you only generate one weight
vector in some Gaussian noise around it
but you actually get all these cryptic
shapes and structures and it's hard to
interpret it interpret them but they're
definitely curved and nonlinear and I
think that's another indication that of
diversity and that's all
yeah so the question was the
relationship between the size of the
target network in hyper network so in my
case the hyper network was about 30
times as big as the target network but
if you try to count how many different
weight vectors that my hyper network can
actually generate so it's hard to count
but effectively I think I managed to
generate meant much more than 30
different weight vectors so yeah that
were good weight vectors so that means
that my hyper network actually learned
some relationship more and more than
this memorized 30 different weight
vectors generates weights the
architecture of the hyper network oh oh
yes okay yeah I oh yeah
best idea here only generates weights
for a given fixed architecture there are
ideas of how to generalize this for
generating various topologies or
architectures but I think that's more
complicated yes okay so the question was
how does this work compared to Bayesian
deep networks so I did some comparison I
mean there are a lot of methods of
Bayesian deep networks so I took this
one which was easy for me to reproduce
and I mean it's it's I get comparable
results first of all inside depending in
which aspects in some aspects I get
better results
some aspects they get better results but
this can also be seen it could also be
seen as a bayesian at the Bayesian
framework it's I think well this it's a
bit philosophical but I think the
Bayesian framework is has a lot of flaws
in it but basically this is also
also be seen as a Bayesian idea yeah
okay thanks
[Applause]